una escalera de 20 metros está inclinada
sobre una pared la distancia x 7 entre
el pie de la escalera y la pared crece a
una tasa de 3 metros por minuto en
cierto tiempo de subíndice 0 la parte
superior de la escalera está a una
distancia bien
dt subíndice 0 de 15 metros sobre el
suelo cuál es la tasa de cambio del
ángulo theta dt que se forma entre el
suelo y la escalera en ese instante
viena lo primero que haremos es hacer un
boceto del problema
después nos preguntaremos qué ecuación
nos ayudaría a resolver este problema y
con esto vamos a resolver el problema
así que veamos una escalera de 20 metros
está inclinada sobre una pared bueno por
aquí voy a poner a mi pared ok
déjame poner que esta es mi pared ok
bueno también necesito el suelo
supongamos que por aquí tengo el suelo
ok
este es el suelo y tengo una escalera
recargada en la pared así que voy a
poner por aquí una escalera que está
recargada en la pared y bueno empieza en
el suelo y sabemos que esta escalera
mide 20 metros
20 metros y después nos dicen la
distancia x dt m entre el pie de la
escalera y la pared crece a una tasa de
3 metros por minuto
ok entonces la distancia que hay de aquí
a acá esta distancia se llama x de tema
déjame ponerle nombre x
dt y sabemos que crece a una tasa de 3
metros por minuto es decir que x prima
de t ok o lo que es lo mismo esto
podemos escribirlo como la derivada de x
con respecto al tiempo sabemos que esta
tasa de cambio es de 3 metros por minuto
de lujo y por otra parte me dicen que en
cierto tiempo t subíndice 0 la parte
superior de la escalera está a una
distancia bien
dt subíndice 0 de 15 metros sobre el
suelo
es decir que esta distancia esta
distancia que va de aquí al suelo ok
tiene el nombre de james d
y bueno me dicen que en un instante
texto 2007 subíndice 0 es 15 metros
sobre el suelo entonces déjame ponerlo
bien de este instante de sub 26 0 es
igual a 15 metros o también lo podemos
escribir aquí si estamos en ese instante
podemos decir que en el instante de
subíndice 0 ok
esta altura vale 15 metros 15 metros
bueno y ahora nos preguntan lo siguiente
cuál es la tasa de cambio del ángulo
teta dt que se forma entre el suelo y la
escalera en ese instante
ok observa estamos fijándonos en este
ángulo en este ángulo que voy a llamar
theta y este ángulo también es una
función del tiempo eso es importante
cambia con respecto al tiempo ahora
siempre que tengamos problemas con tasas
de cambios relacionadas
lo mejor es escribir una ecuación
algebraica tal vez en este caso requiere
algo de trigonometría que relacione
todas estas cosas y después tomaremos la
derivada de ambos lados de esta ecuación
para así relacionar las tasas de cambio
y veamos queremos saber cuál es la tasa
de cambio del ángulo de tap dt que se
forman entre el suelo y la escalera en
ese instante es decir esencialmente lo
que queremos es cuánto vale teta prima
y nos dan algunos datos importantes
sabemos que la tasa de cambio de x con
respecto al tiempo es constante es de 3
metros por minuto y sabemos cuánto vale
en ese instante tiempo de prima de t
subíndice 0 es de 15 metros así que hay
formas de establecer una relación entre
x y theta esto porque tenemos la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo
para obtener la derivada de theta con
respecto al tiempo y después usar la
información de dt subíndice 0 ok
hay formas de relacionar a x con teta
bueno simplemente hay que usar un poco
de trigonometría porque si multiplicamos
la hipotenusa por el co seno de este
ángulo theta voy a obtener x entonces
déjame notarlo
xd te lo podemos ver si relacionamos a x
con tdt como la hipotenusa que en este
caso vale 20 metros la hipotenusa que
multiplica al goce no de teta que a su
vez es una función del tiempo al coseno
de teta dt lo escribo así para que se
vea claramente que es una función del
tiempo y bueno esto sale simplemente de
la definición de las funciones
trigonométricas básicas ahora por qué es
esto útil bueno pues vamos a pensar qué
es lo que pasa cuando tomamos la
derivada de ambos lados de esta ecuación
usando la regla de la cadena en el lado
izquierdo voy a obtener bueno la
derivada de esto es simplemente x prima
de t ok y del lado derecho obtengo
primero la derivada del coseno
con respecto a theta lo cual es menos 20
no olvidemos este 20 por el seno de teta
por el seno de eta
dt ok
y esto habrá que multiplicarlo
utilizando la regla de la cadena por la
derivada de lo de adentro con respecto
al tiempo es decir por la derivada de
teta con respecto a t por lo tanto este
subíndice cero que es el instante que me
importa la derivada de teta con respecto
a tem entre sus 20 c zero va a ser igual
a quien bueno podemos saber cuánto vale
x prima de tm porque nos lo dicen acá
arriba puedo intentar encontrar el valor
de menos 20 el seno de teta ente
subíndice 0 y solamente me quedaría
despejar a teta prima de t subíndice 0
así que hagámoslo
igual a t subíndice 0 obtengo que bueno
x prima de tema para toda tema es de 3
metros por minuto esto suponiendo que
las tasas de cambio están en metros por
minuto la distancia está en metros y por
lo tanto los ángulos están en radiales
entonces usando esta información me
quedaría que 3 es igual a menos 20 por
el seno de tener entre subir 0 por la
derivada de theta ente subíndice 0 ahora
cómo podemos encontrar el seno de
detente subíndice 0 bueno usemos la otra
información que nos dan
sabemos que el seno detectan entre
subíndice 0 bueno esto va a ser el
opuesto entre la hipotenusa así que
déjame notarlo
el seno de eta / sub índice 0 ok esto va
a ser igual al opuesto que es 7 y dt
pero ante subíndice 0 ok esto dividido a
su vez entre la hipotenusa que ya
sabemos que es 20 metros pero lo bueno
es que sabemos cuánto vale bien
dt subíndice 0 nos lo dan nos dicen que
es 15 metros por lo tanto esto serían 15
entre 20 lo cual es simplemente tres
cuartos
y entonces puedo sustituir este seno de
teta entre su 26 0 por tres cuartos
déjame ponerlo esto de aquí ahora
sabemos que vale tres cuartos
entonces me va a quedar esto por tres
cuartos ok y esto a su vez que
multiplica a la derivada de teta con
respecto a t entre subíndice cero esto
por la derivada de teta con respecto a t
en temps sub índice cero bien ahora sólo
falta despejar teta prima
dt subíndice cero y hemos acabado
entonces menos veinte por tres cuartos
bueno esto de aquí es menos 15
y ahora sí ya puedo decir que te
deprimas dt subíndice 0 de la prima de
este subíndice 0 va a ser igual a bueno
tengo 3 entre menos 15 3 entre menos 15
o lo que es lo mismo a menos un quinto
ok y bueno en este caso mis unidades son
radiales por minuto
radian es por minuto
y ya está observa este problema fue
bastante interesante porque nos dan el
dato de cuánto valen
dt subíndice 0 que eso lo utilizamos
para obtener el seno de teta entre
subíndice 0 y por otra parte
necesitábamos la ecuación que
involucrará a equis y zeda dt ok eso es
todo
hasta la próxima